Well, good morning church.
Uh, anybody else tired?
Uh, I think if you see anybody wearing these shirts today,
they probably are, uh, kids and leaders included.
I actually slept through my alarm this morning,
so it's been, I'm dragging
and kind of skating around this morning pretty quickly.
But listen, it was, it was powerful
to see God at work all week.
It really was an honor to be a part of it,
to watch student leaders
and adult leaders to watch the kids be responsive
and engaged from the jump Monday night.
They were ready to worship and engage in God's word
and so special and a blessing to be a part of it.
Well, today we come to the penultimate sermon
of this series called Realigned through Romans 12.
If you don't know what that word means,
that means next week is the last one.
This is the next to last one.
Uh, and if you're new to our church, that means one thing
that as we finish out a long series, you'll see some
of us dressed up, uh, to honor the time
that we've spent in a long series like this.
You don't have to participate if you don't want to,
but it just means don't be shocked
when you show up next week.
Like, is there a funeral today? No, it's okay.
We got, uh, just the end of a series.
That's what we're doing. But today we come to
what is possibly the hardest command
in all of Romans 12.
Remember, we're seeking to realign our lives
to the perfect standard of Jesus.
Now he shows us what a life lived perfectly looks like.
And so what we've also seen every week is
how far from this standard we actually are.
We measure off of different standards and different things
and, and we don't match it.
And so we've been challenged
and convicted every week as we see how far off of
that standard we are,
but also in some way it feels like all
of them have been building to this one today, that
they've gotten progressively harder
as they've dug deeper into our souls,
they've pushed us further.
All leading to today where we're talking about
loving your enemies, like those who oppose you,
those who are against you, those
who hurt you, how do you love them?
And, and how did Jesus model that perfectly for us?
What can we learn from how he did it
that we can apply today?
And here's why this is so important
because maybe more than any of the other ones,
this command best reveals the transformation
that God has brought in your heart.
Like this is what we talked about
with the kids all week at camp.
This, this very thing that if we stop
and reflect on what God has done for us,
How can we not turn around
and love others, including our enemies?
Because the reality is every single one of us from birth
on our own, apart from any intervention by God,
we are all enemies of God due to our sin against him.
Like we don't deserve his love.
We deserve his wrath, we deserve his judgment.
And yet Romans five, eight,
while we were still sinners, his enemies,
Christ died for us.
Like that's stunning, isn't it?
Like that reality of him loving his enemies, his his,
his ones who are opposed to He loves us.
He's, he's just overwhelming to us to think about that.
And so as we get into this today, keep that gospel
at the forefront of your mind.
Like that is the foundation
for everything else we'll talk about today.
That's the foundation of what we're gonna see, of how
to love our enemies and how to apply all
of this really in Romans 12.
And so this is hard. It's difficult.
So let's pray and ask God for help.
Lord, we come humbly
before you asking you in your grace
and mercy that you shine through your word,
that you speak, get me outta the way.
And you speak through what you've written down
and the importance of it.
And in spite of the difficulty of it, God, we would see
and hear and not just be hearers of it,
but doers of the word as well.
Lord, protect us from the enemy who's gonna throw defeaters
in our minds all day about this.
Keep us just focused on seeing you
and your word today In this maybe most
critical command to show what your work is in our lives.
Help us God, in Jesus' name. Amen.
So we'll be back in Romans 12 as we've been all summer.
So turn there with me
and we're actually gonna look at a couple verses
in the chapter over the last few weeks.
We've looked at phrases from verses.
But this one we're gonna see actually a couple whole
verses in this.
'cause Paul had a lot to say.
In fact, this is the thing he talks about the most in this
entire section, is this idea
of loving your enemies maybe 'cause it's that important.
But we're gonna start in verse 14.
There's one radical command right off the bat here.
We'll see more as we get later.
But just verse 14 for now, watch this.
Bless those who persecute you.
Bless and do not curse them.
Okay, so let's just remember the context of
what was happening back in Rome
that would've precipitated Paul writing this
to the Roman Christians.
Remember that the early church was not popular,
nor was it prevalent.
Like there weren't church buildings on every corner.
It wasn't culturally acceptable to be a Christian back then.
In fact, they thought you were a cult
or they thought you were trying to take over Rome
and overthrow Caesar.
And so they were not for you,
which means they would've been persecuted,
not actually celebrated.
They would've been called names they would've been laughed
at, they would've been probably fired from jobs thrown in
prison, possibly even physically harmed, merely for saying,
I identify with Jesus Christ.
They would've been experiencing the worst evil
that the enemy could throw at them through the pagan world
that they lived in.
Yet this is how the Christian life turns
that world upside down
where the world says get even.
Jesus says, get blessing. The world says get even.
Jesus says, no. Get about blessing. Go bless people.
Go bless them. We actually get our word eulogy from this
word for blessing.
What's a eulogy at a funeral, right?
It's you saying honorable things kind,
blessing things about the person who's died.
That's a eulogy. That's the word we get it from here.
The blessing that he's saying we should give to those
who persecute us.
So notice what he's saying.
He's not saying, just be polite to your enemies.
Be nice to your enemies.
Like this is the explosive power of the gospel
entering into a fallen world where instead of cursing
or attacking your enemies, you are
to bless your enemies.
That is radical. That is completely counter-cultural.
And notice it's not just bless those enemies
who are actually nice to you at that moment, moment.
It's when they are per, when they are persecuting you.
Bless those who per, that's an active word.
Bless those who are persecuting you right now.
He says, we're not to curse them back.
We're to bless them back.
And here's what that does.
When you bless someone back who's persecuting you, it
reverses their hatred, blessing.
Instead of cursing when someone hates you,
someone persecutes you and you, you don't curse them back.
You instead bless them back.
It reverses the hatred that they've tried to attack you
with it reverses it back.
What they thought would get to you
actually comes back to them as blessing.
Like they thought they'd get at you,
they thought this would work.
This would be the thing. This would be the one
that that takes 'em out.
This would be the one that really gets that Christian down.
And what they get in response is blessing.
When someone cuts you down, you build them up.
When someone slanders your name,
you speak well of their name.
When someone attacks you, you love them.
Well, Like this, this is,
this is completely radical.
I was trying to think of a way to illustrate this and,
and this is probably a terrible illustration,
but it's kind of like the reverse card in the game.
Uno, you know like how
that game simply works, right?
It's the order of play is coming clockwise.
You play the reverse card and it goes back counterclockwise
and, and, and simple, right?
This is not complicated. It's not hard to understand.
Here's the thing about it though.
It actually blesses the next person, the person next to you.
And I'm probably way over analyzing this simple card game in
thinking of this way, but I'm trying
to figure out how to illustrate this.
But, but imagine this, right?
So it's coming your way and you play the reverse card
and the person next to you, it blesses them
by giving them an opportunity to play another card instead
of waiting all the way around the circle to
where they have to play again.
Okay? That didn't work. All right?
So when we bless our persecutor,
it's the ultimate reverse card.
What it does is it takes
what they thought was gonna hurt you and it reverses them
and it it takes the the hate and it turns into blessing.
It's the Christians' war cry against evil
Because when we bless our persecutor, we are proving
that we are sons
and daughters of the one
who loved us when we were his enemies.
Like that's the reversal of this.
It's not like it's it's I for an eye thing anymore.
It's no, I am stead completely different now.
I've loved you like Christ has loved me.
It's just illustrating
what Jesus did while hanging on the cross.
He didn't curse those who nailed him to the cross.
What did he do? He blessed them.
He said, father, forgive them
for they know not what they do.
He didn't curse back. He blessed back.
Like that's the standard.
If you think, man, I I'm good at that.
I got that one taken care of. I love my enemy's real well.
If they would be killing you, could you look at them
and say, I forgive you.
Like Stephen in Acts seven who's getting stoned
for merely standing up
and saying, Jesus is Lord, he's getting killed.
And as he's doing it, he's looking
and saying, God forgive them.
Could you say that That's the standard.
Could you be living that out? That's the standard.
So I think we're pretty far from that most of us.
But that's our prayer is that this is the standard
that shows up daily for us in huge ways.
Maybe you would be persecuted and and killed for your faith,
but also in small ways every day as you face
hardship or pain or suffering
or hurt from someone, that you can love them
instead of cursing them back.
So it reverses their hatred.
But actually Romans 12 goes further with this.
Look at verses 17 and 19 now
and follow this with me starting in verse 17.
Repay no one evil for evil,
but give thought to do
what is honorable in the sight of all.
Now verse 19, Beloved never
avenge yourselves,
but leave it to the wrath of God for it is written,
vengeance is mine.
I will repay, says the Lord.
Now we've talked a lot about pride
and humility over the last couple weeks.
This strikes at the very heart of our pride.
The fact that we feel like we need to settle the score,
that we need to make it equitable.
If we're hurt, then we need to hurt back.
It's gotta be fair. That is a prideful heart.
Now, before we go further, I need
to make a little side note here
and to make a clarification,
we're not talking in this about justice
by the state, the government.
'cause in the very next chapter, chapter 13,
Paul talks about the sword meaning justice,
that God has given that to the state, to the government
to bring peace and to keep peace
and to have legal standards and to bring justice
and to protect people.
That's definitely part of it.
But we're talking about here today is personal vengeance.
We're talking about personal responses
to slights, to persecution, to hurts.
How do we respond individually?
Well, if you just followed what Romans 12 said,
it's very clear We are not to repay evil for evil.
We are not to avenge ourselves.
We are not to try and settle the score ourselves.
And notice it's not most of the time
like it's only true in small stuff,
but man, when it's really bad
or when they deserve it, then you can take revenge.
But most of the time you're not supposed to take No, no.
Did you see it? We are not to take vengeance.
We are not to seek revenge ever.
That that's what it says. You can't make anything out of
that other than what that is like.
You are not to take vengeance. Why?
He says it because vengeance belongs to God alone.
That's what Paul does here in verse 19.
He cites Deuteronomy 32 35.
This is from the Old Testament. This is from the law of God.
This was God revealing his character, revealing his nature,
saying This is who I am, this is what I'm about.
And God said the same thing that we have quoted here.
He said it vengeance is mine. I will repay.
God owns it. God takes it away from anybody
else and says it's mine.
I own vengeance. I will be the one to repay.
That means God will settle every account,
every wrong will be made right
either at the cross
where Christ bore God's full wrath for sin.
That's where justice came.
Or maybe in this life that person reaps what they sow
that may be justice or for sure in hell
where the unrepentant will face the full wrath
of God forever.
Justice will be done. Every wrong will be made right?
Justice will come. And when we trust that, here's the point.
Leaving vengeance to God trusts his sovereign justice.
That That he is sovereign. We trust God.
We trust that you're going to bring justice in your time
and your way at your call
sovereignty that he will and he can.
When We leave vengeance to God, it trusts his
sovereign justice.
Now what I'm about to say is gonna get kind of hard
when we take revenge into our own hands.
We are playing God.
We're saying to God, I don't trust you
to handle this, so I'm gonna handle it.
God, I don't trust your timing on this.
I think it should happen quicker.
I think it should happen now.
And so I'm gonna take care of it.
I don't trust you enough to deal with it.
Like you see how crazy that sounds when we say it that way.
But isn't that what we do?
Because here's the, here's the question.
Do we have perfect knowledge of the entire situation to
where we would make a perfect decision on how to handle it?
No. Do we have
perfect knowledge of what's coming around the corner?
Like what's gonna happen in the next minute,
the next hour, the next day?
We have no idea what's coming.
Do we have perfect knowledge of what's actually best
for everyone involved in every situation?
No. So we should leave
vengeance to God, the one
who has perfect knowledge, the one who knows
what his plan is and what is coming around the next corner.
The one who knows what's best for every single person,
every situation, he knows all those things.
He is sovereign. He knows all.
And so when we list, when we release Our
supposed right to revenge,
we walk out of that prison of bitterness
in full trust that God's gonna take care of it.
'cause that's what bitterness is, right?
I don't, I, I don't wanna release this in my heart towards
somebody who's hurt me because I want them to pay.
I want them to suffer because I suffered or I want that.
That's, that's bitterness, right?
It's holding onto that in my heart
that I hope they get what they deserve.
That's, that's a prison.
If we could just release that in full trust
of a sovereign just God
and say, you've got this, God, you, you take care of this.
I know you will. I know you.
It may not be on my timing,
it may not be when I could even see it happen,
but I trust you and I'm free from
what held me down before.
When you entrust your pain
to the perfect judge who sees all, who knows all
who will make all things right, that is not weakness.
That is strength. Because you're trusting in a,
you have absolute confidence in a God who is sovereign
and just that's strength, that's not weakness.
That's not saying I, I don't wanna do anything about it.
I'm just getting outta the way. No, it's, it's trust
and that's strong in the kingdom of God.
Just think about how Jesus modeled this for us.
There was a principle in his day of an eye for an eye,
a tooth for a tooth, this legalistic sense of justice
that if they did this to you, you can do that back to them.
Watch how he flipped that whole thing on its head.
This is in the sermon on the Mount Matthew five verses
38 through 48.
Very familiar. You might have heard this stuff before,
but just listen with the ears now of
what we've been through so far.
Jesus says, you've heard that it was said an eye
for an eye and a tooth for a tooth.
But I say to you, do not resist the one who is evil.
But if anyone slaps you on the right
cheek, turn them the other.
Also, if anyone would sue you
and take your tunic, let him have your cloak as well.
If anyone forces you to go one mile, go with him two miles,
give to the one who begs from you.
Do not refuse the one who would borrow from you.
You have heard that it was said,
you shall love your neighbor and hate your enemy.
But I say to you, love your enemies
and pray for those who persecute you so that you may be sons
of your father who is in heaven, for he makes his son rise
on the evil and on the good sends rain on the
just and on the unjust.
For if you love those who love you, what reward do you have?
Do not even the tax collectors do the same.
And if you greet only your brothers,
what more are you doing than others?
Do not even the gentiles do the same?
You therefore must be perfect
as your heavenly father is perfect.
Does that not sound radical to our modern ears?
Wait a second, listen, you're telling me
that I I I shouldn't defend myself.
Is that what Jesus is saying here?
Here you're telling me I need to just give money away
to people who are trying to steal from me.
Is that what he's saying here? It sounds so radical
because we have such, uh, we've marinated in this culture
of justice and, and injustice and
and fighting for what's yours and keeping yours
and all this stuff and and when we've marinated that so long
that this sounds so radical.
But Jesus said this is the kingdom way.
And Jesus not only taught about it, he lived it.
This is how he loved his enemies,
how he trusted his sovereign father.
This is one Peter 2 21 through 23 says for
to this you've been called
because Christ also suffered for you, leaving you an example
so that you might follow in his steps.
He committed no sin, neither was deceit found in his mouth,
meaning he didn't deserve anything he was getting.
But when he was reviled, he did not revile in return
when he suffered, he did not threaten
but continued entrusting himself to him.
Who judges justly
Said, my father knows
best he will judge.
He will make it all right. I trust him.
So while we may not understand it always
and as hard as it can be to do
leaving vengeance to God, trust
that he will work it out way better than you
and I ever could and you trying
to work it out might actually get you in trouble.
So trust him. Let him handle it in his time and his way
and release the bitterness of it so
that you can walk in freedom.
Well, you might be asking the question, well, okay,
what do I do then if I'm not supposed to fight back,
if I'm not supposed to, to revile and return?
What do I do if I don't take matters into my own hands?
What do I do then in response?
Because hear me, we're not supposed to be passive.
So Romans 12 will continue to show us we're not supposed
to be passive in this.
Just taking hits, doing nothing about it.
Listen to Romans 12 verses 19 through 21.
This is finishing the chapter.
This is a contrast between what we should do
and what we often do.
Romans 1219 through 21, beloved never avenge yourselves,
but leave it to the wrath of God for it is written,
vengeance is mine, I will repay, says the Lord.
Here's what we do to the contrary.
If your enemy is hungry, feed him.
If he's thirsty, give him something to drink for.
By so doing, you will heap burning coals on his head.
Do not be overcome by evil but overcome evil with good.
This is the Christian's secret weapon against evil,
not retreat, not retaliation.
Radical love like this is
saying you could try to gain power through revenge,
but this is saying the power
of transforming love is far greater than anything you can
manipulate and work out yourself.
Love actually is greater again, not passive non-resistance,
just kind of waiting it out, getting shot at all the time.
No, this is aggressive love toward them.
This is saying that we don't just
refuse to harm our enemies.
We actually actively seek their welfare.
We actually meet their physical needs.
We show them practical kindness. That's what this is saying.
Our goal is to love them into God's kingdom,
to reveal something different that we have
that others don't have.
And what did God's word say that all that would do
to the person who is persecuting you.
It says, as you tangibly love them,
you'll heap burning coals on their head.
Now obviously that's not to be taken literally like this
December, you invite them over for a game of Uno
and you put 'em right next in front of the fireplace
and you heap the coals on their head as they're sitting.
That's not what this is saying to do.
These coals are shame
and conviction that burn in the conscience
whenever say for example, someone has tried to hurt you,
persecute you, and all you get back in response,
all they get back in response is love it.
It's so confusing
because what it does is it's,
it's saying like That person wants to hurt you,
and all they get is, is love back.
Their hatred is reversed into love
and it creates a moral crisis in their heart
because they realize in that moment how much they are doing
that is so different than you are.
Their hatred is exposed by your love
and that only does a work in their heart.
You are not supposed to take revenge.
You're allowing God to work in their heart as you love them,
as you bless them back.
That creates something in themselves that is this idea
of coals of shame and conviction in their heart.
And so we, we get that.
I think we can understand and probably have seen that happen
before in this world,
but when we think about doing this man
that seems impossible, doesn't it?
To really love someone who's hurting me
to really love someone who's persecuting me,
that sounds so impossible.
Or when you think about the scale of evil in our world,
how pervasive it is, like
how could good ever win?
Look, look at this. Look at the world like how could good
ever win out over all of this around us?
But Man,
this is the great reversal of the kingdom of God.
Many of Jesus' parables talk about the kingdom
of God being something that seems so small, seems
so insignificant and it just begins to grow slowly
and all of a sudden it takes over everything.
That's the idea here is that yeah, evil is pervasive,
evil is all around us,
but the great reversal in the kingdom of God is
that evil seems strong, but good is stronger.
Love is mightier than hate. Light conquers darkness.
That is the kingdom of God.
We're not just resisting evil,
we are actually overcoming evil with good.
That's the point when overcoming evil with good,
that conquers the darkness like we have darkness all
around us, it conquers it.
When we overcome evil with good,
we should never deny that our world is pretty dark.
We got a lot of darkness all around us,
but we have a couple options in how we can respond to that
Darkness.
We could sit back and just complain about it.
We could throw stones at it.
Look at how evil these people are.
Look at how dark this world is and we could just sit back
and lob grenades at it
or, Or we could start shining some
light into the dark world.
Those are options that we have.
We could try bringing in some good
to overcome the evil that's all around us.
We could look at it and try to avoid it
and stay away from it and complain about it.
Or we could start bringing good into the evil.
We could remember that we're not victims here, man.
Look at how dark the world is. Well, we're so sorry.
We're so sad we live here. No, we're not victims.
We are actually by the overcoming love and power of God.
We are victors in this world.
Jesus talks about, yes, in this world you'll have trouble,
but take heart because I have overcome the world.
That's hope. We have.
We're in Christ, which means we are victors over the
darkness and over the evil already.
So why are we overwhelmed
that we can't see good overcome evil?
In fact, that's what you were designed for Christian
to bring good into the world.
That was, That was one of the major themes.
I preached all week about this at kids camp
and we looked at Ephesians two, the transformation
that comes whenever you are dead in your sin, far from God,
separated from him, hopeless in the world.
But God rich in mercy brought about this transformation
through the gospel to make you alive in
him by grace, through faith.
You did nothing. You can earn nothing.
You should boast about nothing.
But then listen to how Ephesians two ends,
that section it says, for we are his workmanship,
created in Christ Jesus for good works,
which God prepared beforehand that we should walk in them.
That's what God did when he saved you.
He set it up uniquely that you can show him off
to a world that is dark in ways that only you can,
that he designed for you to do it.
And that is through good works, overcoming evil with good.
He wasn't a perfect man, but in the face of much evil
and hatred, Martin Luther King Jr.
Tried to exemplify this concept as best he could.
I know he had moral faults, he had theological faults.
But in the midst of an intense battle in America
for whether African Americans were gonna be treated
as equals or not, He tried to love
like he, he was faced with much
intense threats to him and his family.
He took heat from all sides.
He paid a high price,
but his focus was on loving people who hated him.
There's a quote that he wrote, said, talked a lot about,
we'll put it on the screen as well so you can see this, but,
but listen to what he said.
Returning hate for hate.
Multiplies hate adding deeper darkness
to a night already devoid of stars.
Darkness cannot drive out darkness.
Only light can do that Hate cannot
drive out hate.
Only love can do
that church.
This is what it looks like to live as a citizen of heaven
while still here on earth.
This is how we show a watching world,
that our God reigns over all things.
That we can trust him with the future.
That we don't have to take anything into our own hands.
We can trust that he's gonna do it and he reigns over all.
'cause when they see us, bless instead of curse,
when they see us trust God's justice
instead of seeking revenge.
When they see us overcoming hatred with love,
when they see all of that, they see something
that can only be explained by the gospel of Jesus Christ.
They see something that can only be produced
as we reflect on the great love of God for enemies like us,
that we can love our enemies just like that.
So let's pray towards that end together.
And I just want us to take some time to reflect on this
in light of his word, as we seek
to realign our lives back to the standard of Christ,
just reflect for a moment, first on the gospel of Jesus,
that he would love an enemy like you,
to make you his child,
to adopt you into his family.
That is stunning
to pay for your life, your redemption with his son's life.
It's overwhelming.
And so maybe you are a believer here today,
and this, this I pray, is reawakening
something in your heart for his great love for you,
his personal love for you.
Just rejoice in that.
Let that fill you so much
that you overflow with love for others.
Or maybe you don't know that love
and you've, you've just seen today that he's,
or maybe over the last few weeks
or once he's, he's been stirring your heart
to say that, man, you're not a believer.
You don't know me. I don't know you.
Let's, let's, let's take that reality today.
And if that's you and just run
to him, you feel unworthy.
You don't feel like you can measure up.
He doesn't ask you to do that before you come to him.
He did it for you. So run freely to him
in faith, in his life, death and resurrection for you.
He saves those who come to him by faith.
All of us though, need to reflect on this
application of what we've seen in God's word.
Just a couple questions.
The question is not whether someone has wronged
you, every one of us.
The question is, will you trust God enough
to love your enemies?
Do you trust him to release it
and love them instead?
Maybe not trust them but to love them?
Will you believe that his way
of overcoming evil is better than the world's way?
You don't have to take revenge.
You don't have to take matters into your own hands.
You can trust God. Do you trust God's way?
That good, that love will overcome darkness
and hate
tying it with the gospel again?
Then will you let the love of Christ
so fill your heart?
That blessing flows out to everyone around you, even those
who persecute you
to be filled with the love
and the spirit of God
that it overflows in blessing.
Lord, this is hard. This is so hard.
Help us, God.
Church is in a moment
as we sing the rest of the time together.
If you maybe are wrestling with maybe some unforgiveness
or bitterness in your heart
and you just want someone to pray for you
or talk with someone briefly about that,
or maybe talk about what it means to be a believer,
Christian, we have a prayer team just set up against the
walls here, inside this room on the sides during the songs.
So at any point, just slip outta your seat, go talk
to somebody if you need to or after.
But let's just rejoice
and respond first to his great love for enemies like us.
So if you're able to stand together, sing with faith.